the wind this is one of the most
difficult most brilliant problems in the
history of chess it's for the chess
masters so I know this one is a very
difficult one how many of you would like
to go here why not
scure again how many of you would like
to go here then my ripping okay so if
you can't go back and you can't go here
and you can't go here what's left so I
have only one move remaining check young
man okay
if you move your king to h3 I get my
rook behind your pawn
young man where would you move if you
were white correct
did everybody understand why he moved
his king to g3 okay now your guys are
threatening to promote to a queen and
I'd be lost I'd be lost that would be
terrible for me so I have to give you
one more time a Czech young man in the
blue bingo
brilliant King to f2 now I can't do that
skewer I can't do the skewer
all the way then you guys are
threatening to promote so I want to make
a draw now we're about to enter the
critical position yeah okay you guys
ready for this I want to make a draw so
I play this move now you guys have all
the position on your tables and work
together and you tell me what move
you're going to play with white how many
of you want to promote the pawn to a
queen promotable so I see a lot of
people raise their hands that they
promote the pawn to a queen just a
moment just amendment if you promote the
pawn to a queen it's my turn it's my
turn I then play check
what move can I make stalemate yes young
man but you can't this is the problem so
just okay everybody everybody just pay
attention if you keep your voices down
for just a moment keep your voices down
just for a moment if you make a queen
which is what you guys want to do so you
could win I play here and you're forced
to take my rook otherwise I'll take your
queen and it still mate so you okay okay
so in this position you guys analyze on
the table together this is the critical
position what are you gonna do with
white how many of you want to promote it
to a queen how many of you have
discovered the correct solution
gentlemen ready how many of you think
this young man is correct that you have
to promote it to a rook yeah
now isn't that clever that's called an
under promotion a very very special
tactic okay but I still want to make a
draw I still want to make a drug I told
you this is a master's class this is for
the most brilliant people in the club to
solve so what is your threat young men
what's the
what's what's the move that would be the
checkmate rook to h8 checkmates my king
oh dear oh yeah
so I block the rook now you guys have to
come up with a very special move
what's the special move okay
don't you guys agree that a king and a
look it's the king and rook is it Rob do
you guys want to draw I'm the chess
grandmaster you should be happy to make
a draw okay now comes the critical
question what should white play move and
win young man with the glasses yes sir
you yeah how many think King the G
threes the right move now you're
attacking my rook so I have to move my
rope let's say I move my rook
down in the booth yes you check mate
check mate so so we're gonna go back
because congratulations
you sold the problem that the most
brilliant minds in the world it took
them months to solve whoa awesome huh
okay let's go back for a moment to
understand a few things now when we look
at this position again with new eyes we
discover some remarkable things first of
all there's only four units on the board
right a king and a king a pond and a
rook that's all that's on the board just
four units and what did we discover we
drew we discovered one tactic here and
it's called a pin right there's a second
tactic and it's called a skewer so
that's two tactics a pen and a skewer
and then we discovered
we discovered another tactic and that
was a a third one which was called under
promotion but had you promoted to a
queen we discover a stalemate right
remember this day all mate you promoted
to a rook you'd promote it to a rook
oops
and now after this move so we haven't we
have a pin a skier an under promotion
stalemate and now we have what is called
a double attack a double attack
you're threatening the rook that's one
attack and you're threatening checkmate
and there's nothing I can do
I'm going to get checkmated before we
leave this problem if I play check don't
all yell out at once if I play check how
many moves would it take you to
checkmate me think about it think about
it you know and that's a lot
how many two three okay now how many of
you how many of you think it will take
five how many think it'll take four how
many of you think it'll take three how
many think - okay
let's imagine White's first move is to
take the rook right and now I have no
choice I have to move my king so what
would you like to do young man it's on
it's on h3 at the moment yes young man
King to g3 so that's your second move
and now they move my King to h1 rook to
f1 check and mate three so it would be
three moves okay you see you guys just
solved a problem that took months for
the most brilliant minds to solve in
1880 that's pretty good yep they were
brilliant they were brilliant now to
complete the class for today and then
you guys can play some chess I'm going
to set up one of the most important
basic problems in chess
do I know the opposition okay I'm going
to give you guys with the white pieces
you guys have white I'll take black now
in this position let us say it's my turn
to move I'll be black I'm going to play
King to f7 now on the tables in front of
you set up this position and you tell me
if you guys can win or not King to d5
would that be a good move because for
you to win the game for you to win the
game you're going to have to promote the
pawn to jefe so that means that your
King at some point in the near future is
going to have to control the king the
square f8 if you move your King away
from the f8 square you're not going to
help your cause so let's first imagine
that you advance the pong then what I do
is I move my King into opposition we
play check
you move your king I move my king back
where King the Jeep I its back and forth
then it's now late okay just a second
and once again we have a stalemate you
have a stalemate so advancing the pond
does not win the game
so after king f7 f5 does not win the
game now your king
the ji-yong gentleman said King to d5
but that doesn't help you control this
square so what else can you do young man
in the back yes correct
Bravo Bravo King f5 moving into
opposition now I have to step aside
let's suggest that I in this position
play King g7 now remember you're going
to have to control the f8 square take a
look to your boards figure out how your
king your White King is going to control
this square so that you can promote your
pawn look at your board look at your
board you've got two minutes two minutes
look at your board young man yes
correct how many of you saw this one
King the e6 Bravo
now there's not much I can do I'm going
to go back and now what do you do to
promote promote how are you gonna do
that how do you do that young man yes
sir and if I move my Kings f6 if I move
my king
correct King to e7 and notice that your
King now controls the f8 square so you
can promote and win the game
sorry precisely you can promote and you
can't be captured so that is how you win
this particular position now we're going
to go back remember remember how you
guys won when I played this move you
guys played King to f5 and you won the
game so now I know you guys are really
clever and you know how to defeat this
move King to f7 I'm going to surprise
you I'm going to play King to f8
now check out your position on your
table and you tell me if you can win the
game if you guys had white in this
position
what should you play what should you
play young man wait wait you forgot you
gotta go back now yes young man what do
you think yes sir
correct King to f6 now again your goal
if you're white is you're trying to
promote this pawn to a queen but for you
to promote the pawn to a queen you're
going to have to control the f8 square
correct okay so imagine my move is King
e8 now what do you do young man okay if
how many of you think you should advance
the pawn
if you advance the pond I play King to
f8 and now and now yes young man in the
blue yes okay Bravo King to e8 young and
advanced the pond King to f8 advanced
upon being the e7 and you Queen well I
want to thank you all for coming
that was really amazing I can't believe
that you guys saw the problem the club
as you know is having classes and
lectures and you're all welcome to
attend and in the meanwhile I wish you
all very good day have a nice time
playing chess with each other and
congratulations to the class of oh very
good